Michael sorry to bother you are you
going to be working down here do you
want these down here no work no work
what's a seven-letter word for purse
actual no starts with an H handbag
thank you
all right everybody take a seat as you
may have heard our branch on the planet
Jupiter is up eight thousand percent in
sales
[Applause]
I have a clock I will see you all
tomorrow bye Stanley love you
it's a long Stanley all right everybody
foreign
we need to pump at a pace of 100 beats
per minute oh okay that's uh hard to
keep track how many is that per hour
How's that gonna help you I will divide
and then count to it right oh okay well
a good trick is to
live by the BG
first I was afraid I was petrified no
it's uh uh uh uh Staying Alive you were
in the parking lot earlier that's how I
know you
okay
everybody everybody listen up I need
your ideas now ideas please right now go
go come on Michael we don't know what
you're talking about wet cement outside
it's drying fast come on this is a
lifelong dream what do I write what do I
write you could put your initials in it
MGS no some idiot named Mark Greg
Sputnik who will claim credit for I
don't it wasn't a lifetime opportunity
people come on here we go
yes when I was a little girl okay
okay come on great let's hear it we
found some wet cements
all right quick hello come on right oh
come on you draw a picture no because
that said that says so much more than
words no come on give me something good
okay I was watching e and I saw Will
Smith outside the Chinese Theater and oh
my God he looks so good damn translate
she's talking about the handprints that
celebrities make in the cement I love it
if you're a real star you'd put your
face in it I love it
that doesn't seem safe I love it
I love it we are here today not to
immortalize a man
but an idea
maybe the idea of a man hurry please
greatness is only skin deep some people
say and that's not true other people
believe it's dangerous outside and in
this case ready that's also and not true
force it in as deep as you can
[Music]
just smile for me and let the Day begin
You Are The Sunshine that lights my
heart within each side will have three
minutes to prepare opening arguments
topic
Hilary Swank is attractive the debate is
whether she's hot what difference does
it make attractive hot beautiful we're
talking about the same thing here huge
difference
a painting can be beautiful but I don't
want to bang a painting okay TMI ladies
are we prepared to let the Kevins of the
world decide anything for us anything at
all
we don't even give him full internet
access
wait what
see that
the obvious symmetry of the face
this is a natural appeal of the
scientific standard of cornophilia
features that are composite average of
many features yes she's attractive but
she's not hot
well since I have no incentive to sell
I've cleaned my car organized my desk
and taken a multivitamin so
what now
okay now I've tried everything did you
prank Dwight
well you like that yeah it's not as fun
if I'm not blowing off work I love you
but I'm kind of busy so I need you to
figure this one out on your
own
[Music]
wasting time here we go hey back off
it's solitaire
Hey kid
you're looking for work talk to me how
far can you reach those lovely long arms
here's
yeah but no how long can you hold that
pretty little breath of yours
good
hey Jim
are you distracting these people we're
working
can you at least try to look busy
the moment dardo put the cupcake in her
mouth her daddy pulled her aside and
said you're too fat No One's Gonna like
you if you're too fat
next time I saw David Geffen was at the
Buffalo Club I love you you gay bastard
I said
you gay bastard us
gave
things are a little slow here and
there's only so much cold calling you
can do in a day
it turns out there's no limit to the
number of cheese puffs you can throw at
someone's face
we're getting pretty good at it
[Music]
movie Monday the only cure I know for
the Monday blues is Varsity Blues let's
go let's go let's go let's go take a
seat down there all right everybody here
yes popcorn anyone yes please please
thank you anyone else
movie Monday started with training
videos but we went through those pretty
fast
then we watched a medical video
since then it's been half hour
installments of various movies
with the exception of an episode of
Entourage which Michael made us watch
six times
eat it you don't have to do that Kevin I
don't know I'm glad this is happening
thank you Michael
why are you eating stem first this is a
new food for me how well should I eat it
the other way
can I get some cheese whiz or
hollandaise no no cheese whiz no
hollandaise no chocolate sauce just eat
it come on here comes the airplane there
you go open open into the hangar there
you go yep eat it
put it in your mouth and just eat it I
hate it I don't care whether you hate it
you said you can do it all right eat it
eat it
you're killing him Michael all right all
right all right
from fluffy Park
let me see if you swallowed it home in
your mouth
under your tongue oh God same thing goes
for quarterly reports they are
unreadable they're just numbers and
boring and black so what I was thinking
is that maybe we should have some sort
of graphic like if we have a bad quarter
put in a storm cloud
and
when we have a good quarter
fireworks
or a race car
doesn't have to be a race car
use your imagination there's this Cube
on the screen it bounces around all day
and sometimes it looks like it's heading
right into the corner of the screen and
at the last minute hits a wall and
bounces away
and we are all just dying to see it go
right into the corner
Pam claims that she saw it one day when
she was alone in the conference room
okay
I believe she thinks she saw it I saw it
I saw it and it was amazing who said I
didn't see it did Jim say that I didn't
see it I saw it we have a lot of
collared paper here why or why do we
keep printing this on white ah come on
yeah
I know
I know it's bland it's never going to
happen you've got to believe Maybe
we could have some sort of riddle wait
for like something that you have to look
for
sort of a where's Waldo oh
all right all right let's quit while
we're ahead that was so awesome that was
awesome
thank you
some days I am just on fire